this house wasn't the target of an air
strike but just look at the damage that
was done when a russian missile hit a
university building on the other side of
the street
repairing the gate
is probably pointless the university has
been hit twice already and yuri reckons
it will be again
but it's about pride
after six months of daily shelling
failure street in mikaela is untouched
um
plastic sheeting covers arena's windows
it just about does the job for now but
when winter comes it will be well below
freezing here
has been telling me that she's got two
windows in her apartment both have been
blown out by explosions
to replace one of those windows would
cost pretty much the same as her monthly
pension
choice
the two women have been friends for more
than 20 years they have each other but
little else
this is what their third floor apartment
looked like afterwards
the windows are now boarded up which
gives them some protection but of course
it also blocks the light so their
electricity is on more than normal and
that costs the money they don't have
she shows us what little they have left
the month they couldn't even afford
bread this morning
there is no end in sight they know that
every morning people in the city venture
outside to see who is alive and who is
not
that's been the grim reality of life
here
for six long months
aleister bunker sky news in mikaela